take a look at what this local Fox
affiliate did with Donald Trump's speech
to the nation earlier this week
now the footage appears to be doctored
showing Donald Trump's sticking out his
tongue between sentences which he didn't
do in the original video now the news
director of q13 admitted this was
problematic this does not meet our
editorial standards and we regret if it
is seen as portraying the president in a
negative light
even before the speech we heard a number
of voices calling for it not to be aired
like they've done with other presidents
and other times the network's should
refuse to turn over the airwaves to
Donald Trump tonight for what they know
objectively to be a steady stream of
lies
first of all just because Trump wants to
address the nation doesn't mean Network
should air it otherwise they're just
passing on his lies unfiltered and some
of the fact-checking also got
interesting for example that trumps
claim that 90% of the heroin in the
United States comes from over the border
was widely criticized because most of
that comes through legal ports of entry
and a wall wouldn't really do much to
change that however one claim that
Donald Trump made about 2/3 of women who
were smuggled across the border being
raped in the process turned out to be
true so conveniently CBS then removed it
from their fact check and US mainstream
media continues to show this reel of
footage of u.s. Border Patrol agents
dumping out and kicking over water that
was left for migrants in the hot desert
areas there's video of Border Patrol
agents dumping water on the ground water
that was meant to be left for migrants
this is from the Tucson based aid group
now the video is supposed to be an
example of cruelty and heartlessness by
immigration enforcers and it certainly
is
however the video first surfaced in 2013
and it was filmed back in 2011
these were Obama's guys they have
nothing to do with Trump's Border Patrol
and it's worth noting that Obama
actually deported more immigrants than
any other president in US history
Washington DC is in a state of paralysis
the government is shut down Donald Trump
is demanding funding for his border wall
and the Democrats are adamant that they
will not give it to him it seems like
the
partisanship and division that is so
widespread in Washington DC has now
found its way onto Americans airwaves
caleb Maupin RT New York
you